there's something else going on if
you're
trying to listen to a podcast one of the
best and first and certainly the most
popular is joe rogan joe rogan tested
positive for the coronavirus and at
which time he hit it with everything he
got he's in great shape he does the ufc
fights but he hit it with uh one of the
things he hit was was iver mechtin and
immediately everyone at cnn started
mocking him saying it's a horse drug
when it's got 2015 it got the nobel
prize for medicine as a breakthrough and
in japan they're using it and they
prescribe it and his doctor prescribed
it so dr sanjay gupta trying to hop a
hawk a book didn't know what he was
getting into well joe asked him to come
on the show and sanjay gupta said i was
told by a lot of people you might not
want to go on there because he might
criticize you and he said i really want
to it's a long platform he said he was
on there for a long time with him no
breaks and it was a good opportunity for
him to talk for three hours right so
watch very carefully because joe rogan
says hey
why did cnn where you are the chief
medical reporter why did they lie about
me taking this animal dewormer
it's about two minutes long worth every
second watch this
horse dewormers not a flattering thing i
get it it's a lie it's a lie on a news
network and it's a lie that's a willing
that's that's a lie that they're
conscious of this is not a mistake yeah
they're unfavorably framing it as
veterinary medicine well the fda put
this thing out you saw that did you see
the thing that the fda put out what did
the fda put out
it was a tweet and it was snarky i admit
it they said you are not a horse you are
not a cow stop taking this stuff or
something like that why would you say
that when you're talking about a drug
that's been given out to billions and
billions of people a drug that was
responsible for one of the inventors of
it making nobel prizes nobel prize in
2015-15 yeah yeah a drug that has been
shown to stop viral replication in vitro
you know that right why would they lie
and say that's horsty warmer i can
afford people medicine
this is ridiculous it's just a lot like
anyone but don't you think that a lie
like that is dangerous on a news network
when you know that they know they're
lying you know that they know that i
took medicine like here it is
this is ivermectin you gotta sit right
here somebody gave it to me
all right hang on i i do the the thing
is we're we're like going so fast like i
feel like i'm missing i'm missing you
that's a problem that your news network
is not lies
well i don't i don't think dude what did
they say they lied and they said i was
taking horse dewormers first of all it
was prescribed to me by a doctor yeah
yeah a long time they shouldn't have
said it was a bunch
if you got a human
pill because there were people that were
taking it the veterinary medication and
i you're not obviously you got it from a
doctor so that it shouldn't be called
that ivermectin can be a very effective
medication
for parasitic disease and as you say
it's probably you know i think what a
quarter billion people have taken it
around the world i get that way more so
way more billions of people have taken
it can i just come back to the one i
want to talk about yeah
before we get to that does it bother you
that the news network you worked for
out and out lied was outright lied about
me taking horse dewormer they they
shouldn't have said that why did they do
that i don't know you didn't ask i
didn't think that was you're the magical
guy over there i didn't ask i should
have asked before but they did it
without such glee no
i watched and he did and jim acosta was
the guy that joe rogan named he goes i'm
watching i'm trying to recover
recovering from this virus i felt good
in 24 hours and i'm watching jim acosta
on the weekend say i'm taking all this
stuff and ridicule me and uh i like i
listened to that whole show he had one
of his comedian friends on and he talked
about that he said now i'm better and
people at cnn are actually upset that
i'm better well held him accountable he
didn't let up and uh you know it has
been in the last couple of years 300
million doses of it have it was
developed uh in the 1970s for two
tropical diseases one was called river
blindness and the other lymphatic of
filariasis or some
i'm sure i'm mispronouncing that
merck donates hundreds of millions of
doses a year
because it is it was developed as a
human medicine it has since been uh used
for veterinary purposes and in fact if
you feed your dog heart guard for heart
worms the active ingredient is ivor but
the bigger picture here is his doctor
prescribed them why is it why are they
criticizing what he decides to take and
put in his body that his doctor gives
him to treat a virus
you know what the bigger picture is uh
when ron johnson interviewed the doctor
who had so much success giving it out as
a therapeutic they took down the senate
testimony when he was in the majority so
they don't want you taking ivermectin
but in japan it's the first thing they
give if you have a virus that's deadly
aren't you going to throw the kitchen
sink at it too right and you go to a
doctor and that's what he did just
listen to the show you find out what he
did and then you find out how he was
ridiculed but from howard stern on down
when you take on joe rogan i don't think
they were prepared to what they got he
as a podcaster and they want to minimize
it but the podcast in today's
environment is as powerful as networks
well sanja gupta at the end of it he
said well i'm glad you're better and joe
rogan said i think you're the only one
at cnn that thinks that well right you
know what it just goes to show you there
are a lot of doctors
they
a lot of doctors give different stuff he
had a doctor who gave that and now
you've heard the whole story and sanjay
says yeah cnn shouldn't have said i'm so
glad we uh played that because it's
anthony fauci uh people just worship at
his feet when he wants to decide whether
we can have halloween or christmas never
brings up therapeutics he always brings
up the vaccine uh and but a vaccine he
predicted wouldn't come out
for 18 to two 18 months to two years it
was out in nine months but in sanjay
gupta's defense he doesn't have he he
doesn't have uh he's not able to look at
every single show on that network and
just determine what's going to be
talked about well if he missed it he
heard it with both ears that's right on
the joe show i went on brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now